Hunter Biden showing up at a Delaware
Courthouse with a freshly shaved head
and officially pleading not guilty to
three federal gun charges the court
laying out the rules for the road for
conditions of his release Hunter's got
to get a real job tell the court if he's
going to leave the country and he can't
have a gun and he also must submit to
random drug testing could be the reason
for the haircut speaking of which he
apparently passed one recently team
Hunter also said to be wrapping his
defense around the Second Amendment
which really puts him at odds with dad's
desire to crack down on guns if you will
sell a gun to someone who's prohibited
from possessing it if you willfully fail
to run a background check if you
willfully falsify a record if you
willfully fail to cooperate with the
Tracy request or inspections my message
you is this we'll find you
and we will seek your license to sell
guns we'll make sure you can't sell
death and Mayhem on our streets you know
Katie uh critics will say well where the
Second Amendment Advocates out to
protect Hunter Biden but they don't
understand lawful gun owners right
lawful gun owners follow the law and
would be just as hard on Hunter as they
would anybody in their family exactly
because they don't want this kind of
stench on them and they don't have to
shave their heads when they go to court
but his lawyers might have a case
actually there was a case in August for
the federal federal appeals court ruled
that a guy who brought a case against
the federal government when he was
charged with a felony for having
marijuana in the car with a pistol that
that is unconstitutional and the appeals
court agree with agreed with him so he
might win on this that's true but the
hypocrisy is incredible because Joe
Biden has been wanting to throw millions
of Americans into prison for Simply
Having a piece of plastic that goes on a
firearm and without out any kind of due
process at all and going around
Congressman law so when it comes to
everything that Joe Biden has said about
crime about drugs in the 1990s and now
about guns he wants regular American gun
owners who are law abiding to do he has
none of those expectations for his son
despite it being all over his laptop but
what is his job going to be I don't know
a dog trainer for Commander he could
teach he could teach painting at a local
school but he's gross painter he spits
through a straw that is true you know uh
judge is a haircut just a haircut or is
there something else going on well you
know we've known Hunter for a long time
and we've never seen him with a buzz cut
so I happen to think that he's now
represented by an attorney who knows
full well that you can pee in a cup they
can test your blood
and a lot of drugs move very quickly
through your system but the part of your
body that drugs don't move quickly
through is your hair and so so I was a
Narcotics judge for over a year and so I
would mandate that certain defendants be
tested by their hair now
um the hair maintains the drug for a
significant period of time even for
years depending upon how long it is
depending upon the toxicity how
concentrated it was and how much was
used by his having a buzz cut when they
go to pull a hair they're not going to
have a sufficient amount to even be able
to test so that he could be clean in a
urine or a blood sample because there
are some things like some marijuana can
go in and out of your system in a matter
of a day or two days or three days but
the hair you could also take pubic hair
but we know from the laptop that he
happens to take care of himself down
there okay so uh what we've got is a guy
who was very Savvy about drug testing
and doesn't want there to be any
evidence about it now I can't I have to
tell you the truth that's what goes on
real courtrooms now let me tell you one
thing Katie about he can maybe based
upon that federal court get away with
one count but it can't get away with the
first two counts he lied on a pistol
permit application and he lied when he
went to buy a gun okay and the other
thing that I think is outrageous that
he's supposed to communicate his
international travel plans to the judge
really why is this guy being allowed to
to travel internationally shouldn't he
even be registered as a foreign agent
before he does that I mean it's just a
sad commentary on all the favoritism
he's gotten yeah uh Jesse I'm not sure
how it affects people who have somebody
else's hair on their head so you're
saying you're safe for now don't pass
any tests yes exactly the guy I got this
was from never touched the stuff exactly
but so I know when women chop their hair
off it usually signifies a major major
emotional
change Jesse it's true and you know it
you know I'm right like Linda Hamilton
and the Terminator if a woman comes in
to work or anywhere and all of a sudden
she said look at next it's gone you know
something's going on you're just not a
fashion trend Katie you're a woman you
know I'm right also I agree with the
judge
you know I did that also I agree with
the judge he was in the room with the
sugar brother remember he was ripping
tubes out the window in Malibu he could
just get contact right there and you
also have the bag of coke what was that
in June so you can't be too careful I
want to know if the art
that he's selling is considered a job
now could you say yes judge I am an
artist and I am selling my paintings for
five hundred thousand dollars to Chinese
donors that is my job I'm not looking
for a nine to five do you can you get
away with that yeah as long as you tell
me who's buying them I'd be happy no you
can't say that no you'll get in too much
trouble all I know is that Joe is gonna
pardon his son uh at some point whether
it's when he's a lame duck and Trump
beats him or after re-election all right
Jessica you can talk about the shaved
head or uh respond to Jesse because you
said no it's not happening part about
the pardon
oh yeah the part that's not happening I
don't need to say more than that I'm
actually still using inside a little bit
that the judge referenced the laptop in
terms of knowing what's going on with
Hunter Biden's lower hair
um which I guess I didn't watch the
video closely enough you got to open a
laptop yep yeah it's Cutting Edge stuff
okay
um so what is still relevant to all of
this is that people don't get prosecuted
for this the data again under 300 people
prosecuted for uh falsifying the
documents to get a gun out of 25 to 30
million people that got background
checks the year that Hunter Biden got
this gun
um Katie's right about the case in
appeals court but it seems like the
Supreme Court decision in 2022 New York
State Rifle A Pistol Association
um versus Bruin is actually going to be
what they use when they bring this up
saying that there was no historical
tradition of firearms regulation when it
comes to people who are drug abusers and
it should be noted as well that there's
discussion of applying this case to
people who were domestic violence
abusers in the past I am firmly on Joe
Biden's side about all this I don't want
people who are high I don't want people
who beat their wives girlfriends
whatever to be able to have access to
guns but you know gotta admire it flip
the script Hunter Biden right so should
he be prosecuted well they don't usually
is no no no no no no they do how many of
those people lied on the application
that's the issue well the issue is not
how many people filed for a pistol
permit nobody lied prosecution it's a
local issue it's not a federal issue the
feds don't get involved in something
unless if there is no other felony like
the people like to throw away the Kodak
Black oh is it called
it's Kodak Black and he was already
convicted of a felony Hunter Biden is a
first-time offender all right Ja Rule
didn't no no no well that's because he
didn't plead
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now